hello and welcome to answer your call
Nero who is that we don't know it means
gambit tirage okay okay so what do I
play I play this line let's go for this
night a form i recently had some issues
with a three with the a 390 for line Oh
set a good timing not quite sure yeah I
want to say what to be want to speed up
here a little bit after I lost the last
game one time and this completely drawn
ruge ending try to be able to quickly
him okay yeah it doesn't look perfectly
coordinated the whole thing there should
be two stuff this God could be five
possibly coming but bit awkward him okay
let's do this not ideal but
yeah tweeners is annoying it's annoying
peace need to unpin the upon get get out
of this somehow so that I have III maybe
if i get to block his pawns this will be
quite nice Quincy five or something that
I have on the agenda Quincy five if he
wants to play Queen a two maybe
I can also do this it should be a little
bit better for me
if it takes see 593 should be okay all
night a for maybe night a for actually
see 493 it's comfortable I can take and
pity for oh I overlooked that but she
also didn't notice it and no one should
be better again
okay if you insist I will take it ok so
I am through it's not so easy to to keep
this
okay I'll take the rook ending might be
a draw of it something that I can try to
play for wind for quite a while cannot
move the King here maybe it is a draw
probably have to play some g 4 kg three
okay
and how to do that still f4 is not
possible
no one blunder f2 oh my goodness ads
been a long day but ah Wow time morning
draw offered the course check check
check check check check
check yeah it's very exciting draw our
third game draw yeah I'm system just a
[ __ ] yeah okay well said it was a long
day with just plundering the earth porn
and yeah anyway hmm he he he had an
opportunity as his opening position here
was kind of okay hydroxy five him that's
a funny move I didn't think about this
at all so I would have won the cranium
it is not so easy to play but it's still
a queen for mine appears on the roof now
okay so this is what I did yeah yet yet
take 64 but played that in a split
second yeah lights III was a blunder I
have to avoid that I have to take maybe
first yend and play this kind of
position which is maybe equal not
totally sure I've got a good blockade of
that porn but now here you can take take
deform oh okay yeah now I'm better but I
probably should do something I mean what
I did lead to that rook ending
yeah that's probably still a draw I mean
porn is nice but it might just be it
wrong while it's it's oddly awful that I
blunder it in one more yeah is there
some way to even get f fine now I can
kind of regroup we'll c 1 e 1 e 2 king g
2 and then some f4 but it would still be
a draw at the end i guess okay well
thanks for watching